[Music]
Shawn Mendes and Camila Cabello showing
off more PDA
[Music]
the pair was spotted holding hands
strolling the streets of New York City
Tuesday oh my God this is a real thing
and check out those Smiles okay yeah
well it's just a little hint I can't
confirm with an eye but I'm basically
the former Flames are seemingly going
strong after their Coachella reunion
last month
[Music]
yeah the two were seen chatting it up
and even locking lips at the music
festival it just feels like oh my God
like we're kissing now at the time A
source told E.T Sean and Camilla aren't
officially back together but are
enjoying each other's company and seeing
where things go I think the truth about
being celebrities and being in a
relationship is that it's super tricky
because there's a lot of people who want
to know
ET Source adds that they're attracted to
each other and care about each other a
lot they are having fun
Sean and Camilla split in 2021 after two
years of dating those feelings are gonna
come and I think you just gather more
and more tools to cope with them in like
healthy ways and following their flirty
Coachella sighting the singers have been
snapped out and about together multiple
times you know he's the best and I think
we're you know always want to see each
other last month the two held hands
during a night stroll in Santa Monica
and I witnessed at the time telling E.T
they looked very comfortable happy and
in love my guy I love that guy then
showing off some PDA earlier this month
while waiting for a comedy show in Los
Angeles
with their latest trip to the big apple
looks like there's nothing holding them
back from giving their romance another
shot I think when you find your person
you feel and you know that you found
your person
[Music]